pour réaliser ce tuto sans me faire
bannir des réseaux sociaux j'ai mis au
point ce prototype composé d'une bourse
en tissu et de deux marrons glacés mais
passons à la
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
démonstration avant d'y mettre les mains
commencez par examiner vos testicules
avec vos
yeux pour éviter un tour de rein
placez-vous face à un miroir et observez
l'aspect la forme et la taille de vos
bourses à la recherche de quelque chose
d'inhabituel ensuite idéalement après
une douche ou un bain chaud pour que
tout le matériel soit bien détendu
souspeser vos testicules en étant bien
attentif à vos sensations pour finir
placer l'index et le majeur derrière le
testicule le pouce devant et faites-le
rouler délicatement entre vos doigts
ensuite recommenencez avec le second si
vous ressentez quelque chose d'anormal
ou d'inhabituel comme une asymétrie par
exemple une vraie hein parce que à la
base c'est normal que les deux soient
pas exactement pareil si vous sentez une
grosseur si c'est plus sensible que
d'habitude prenez rendez-vous chez votre
médecin